now listen you're both sad yourself and
mark we've talked about your parents
start you're quite your firm but fair
yes in the Wahlberg household but you
are very involved like you do you're
very hands-on you go to all the sporting
games oh absolutely yeah but they're
there they're not liking me at the games
anymore I get a little too crazy I got a
little too passionate well I don't know
because they've taken pictures of you oh
look at this you're really going for it
in this next one no coaching I'm not
coaching oh oh nice oh no I'm just with
the other pair okay my wife always
she'll take because I bring these chairs
she takes the chair goes the sits down
the other end that's like she doesn't
know me everyone knows you so don't you
think you should just tone it down just
played on a championship game yeah and I
couldn't even eat I mean my stomach was
in butterflies he's nine and oh god it
was it was crazy I lost my voice for
about a week
screaming yelling what did they win No
so I had to beat him
little red button good night is vark
joking good will you coach my coach I've
experienced the same thing you forget it
be the worst coach why because it could
be down 20 don't worry guys you're doing
really good a lot of positive things
happening okay you learn more you ever
said that out loud well sadly that's
exactly but I did have a moment where I
was screaming at my oldest son he was 10
years old at the time and it's like bad
guys - nice and he stuffs the middlegame
he's like what and I realized I had lost
my mind and I said I just said never
mind
trying to get closer to the ball
but it's hard hard to not get wrapped up
in the excitement as you about a game
usually usually I was growing my
moustache out for anchorman two and
coaching on the sidelines and the
opposing coach was like you look
familiar
and I go yeah you that actor I'm like I
think so they said is that mustache real
I said yes why would I be wearing a fake
honey hold on I got to put my fake so
that I'm
like birth control confusion so I was
like hormonal fell on my face I forgot
to thank the director so I was just like
what does it all mean nothing okay so
darling your supermodel you rock star
Eddie you movie star I'll marry of the
steerer I will go to go